so with just days left in their session
before the holiday break that is
upcoming
uh democrats and republicans in congress
are reportedly getting closer to a
second
coronavirus stimulus package a relief
bill as they are often called
finally at the end of december they are
closer but nothing is yet guaranteed and
i don't actually know what's worse that
it's taken seven months to get close to
a second deal
or what would actually be in this deal
which we found out about over the last
24 to 48 hours because this is a deal
that will include
ungodly amounts of money for many
industries
and it might include it might include
600 direct payments for some
americans now the information is
changing
regularly one estimate was it might be
nine hundred dollars for some americans
600 is the number that aoc and others
are talking about
but the last estimate is it will be a
900 billion dollar total package
with the possibility of 600
indirect payments to americans and in
the meantime
it would include that blanket liability
shield
for companies against coronavirus
related lawsuits that's something donald
trump has been talking about
after the first stimulus package when
discussion of the second one started
donald trump at every opportunity would
say we want the liability shield for
companies and the
understand what this is a lie a
coronavirus liability shield for
companies means that
if there is an employee or a customer
that gets the virus because of how
your business handled social distancing
and and sanitary guidelines etc
you have blanket protection from being
sued for that
and it is essentially just an open door
to companies to do whatever you can to
increase profitability in the short run
with no regard whatsoever to the danger
that you may be placing
your employees or customers or both in
as a result of ignoring guidelines which
may make you more profitable
it's that that would be in there but
they're battling for 600
payments for individuals the package
again as of the latest iteration that
we've seen reporting on it would not
include any assistance to state and
local governments
which is sort of where you need to start
to properly
manage the different ways in which this
is affecting different municipalities
and states so
it's just so pitiful and embarrassing
and pathetic
there's really no other way to say it
600
um some people received 1200 back in may
uh plus those six hundred dollar a week
boosts
in unemployment for people who were laid
off it's been seven months
since that with nothing who knows even
if this is approved
and that's a question mark how quickly
the money would actually be distributed
and make it into people's bank accounts
and they're talking about maybe six
hundred dollars
democrats proposed doing another 1200
and they've been proposing that since
may
that went nowhere some of the more
progressive democrats
including friend of the show who we
spoke to not that long ago
congressman roe khanna have proposed two
thousand dollars some have proposed two
thousand dollars per month
that's all going nowhere very very
quickly and and
the reality is you know i i never want
to scoff at anything
when we know that half the country can't
meet an unexpected 400
expense you see the number 600 and you
say well we that's
we shouldn't scoff at that okay but the
reality is that 600
if you're doing fine doesn't change
really anything
and if you're if you've not been doing
fine since may
then what 600 is going to do materially
i get it you know me
maybe this makes it so you can make half
your rent payment next month and that's
better than nothing
but it's not about beggars can't be
choosers
it's that the argument over whether we
give 600 or 900
to people after seven months of nothing
given the economic situation
communicates a complete lack of
understanding as to what's actually
going on in the united states
for tens of millions of americans right
now even
the first stimulus with the twelve
hundred dollars
it's fine and it was useful for people
but if you were employed at that time
and you were continuing to work to earn
a living uh the the
the twelve hundred dollars was not
likely to affect
your viability financially over the
course of the entire pandemic and that's
why stopping short with that and then
going seven
months with nothing is delusional what
really was the lifesaver for a lot of
people
back in april may was the enhanced
unemployment of an extra six hundred
dollars a week which by the way in large
cities
particularly if you have even just one
child it's barely enough to get by
without working and in some cities it's
not enough to get by
and look at how many businesses were
closed at that time so this is a great
example of how
being cheap is really expensive
and we've talked before there's there
was an interesting article i recommended
it must have been a year ago maybe 10
months ago
about how being poor is really expensive
and it it the article explained you know
if you're poor
you're likely going you're more likely
to go to the bodega in the
on the corner to get four rolls of
toilet paper
rather than ordering the 60 rolls from
amazon which are
better quality and cheaper on a per roll
basis
but you've got to lay out some larger
amount of money up front
and in that sense it's much more
expensive to be poor because you're
often buying items at a higher unit cost
sometimes of lower quality and spending
more time acquiring those items because
you're making multiple trips
instead of you go on amazon and you get
the big box of toilet paper it's an
example
the way it applies here is it actually
applies to a lot of consumer products
you buy the really cheap work boots this
year and you probably have to buy
another pair next year and another pair
next year
or you get and that gets really
expensive in the long run
or you buy the really good boots with
the lifetime warranty
you do have to spend more now but your
long-term cost is lower
the way it applies to stimulus is you do
1200 bucks in may
and maybe 600 now and it sounds like
you're saving a lot of money relative to
giving people
fifteen hundred dollars a month two
thousand dollars a month sounds like
you're saving money
but when you consider that that cash
payments are demand side stimulus and
they stimulate the economy
plus higher long-term payments allow
people to stay home and be more
responsible
which slows the spread and we know that
every person who ends up in the hospital
for corona with coronavirus
places a huge financial cost on the
system you realize
the higher outlay is cheaper in the long
term by suppressing the spread
and case in point you look at european
countries that are only in their second
spike now
that entire summer period in the
northern hemisphere
where they had relatively normal summers
economically was much better
than what we've had here where we are
now on our third peak we had peak number
two
during the summer and it was disastrous
for business and the economy as we
continued to hemorrhage jobs
so that's a long way of saying one of
the richest countries in the world
which some love to say is the greatest
country in the world whatever that means
finds billions for corporations in
certain industries
and we're arguing about 600 for people
it's pathetic
canada did two grand a month for seven
months if you were working but didn't
earn very much
you qualified at least for part of that
some provinces even did additional
payments
so what congresswoman aoc and some
others are saying is if you don't find
the 600
appropriate get in touch now with your
elected officials
and tell them that but really more is
needed i mean
you know if this doesn't justify mass
rallies at urban centers i really don't
know what does
don't these members of congress and
senators work for us and of course
that's true
in theory it's true on paper in reality
they're mostly serving the interests of
big corporations
how disconnected from reality do you
have to be
to think that six hundred dollars after
seven months of nothing
is going to solve a problem and
stimulate the economy
it's completely it's magical delusional
thinking
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important
insights from 10 different books in an
afternoon obviously it's perfect for
exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version
and read it i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video